let's stick with the vaccine theme we
can talk now to labour's
shadow health secretary jonathan ashwa
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning mr ashworth so
it feels like we finally got a glimmer
of light with the promise
of this vaccine do you think the
government needs
a bit of credit here you know they've
invested hundreds of millions of pounds
in
research they've ordered 40 million
doses of the fisa vaccine so the uk's
near the front of the
queue labour of course will always you
know point out when the government's
gone wrong but
do they need a bit of credit well i
think everybody involved in the
vaccine discovery deserves credit
particularly our
our scientists in the united kingdom we
can be immensely proud of what they've
achieved and we've seen some of our
scientists at
imperial there in your package i think a
vaccine is a great hope
for the coming months but we know the
world health organization has warned of
vaccine hesitancy
so i think the government needs to do
two three things and we want to work
with them
on a cross-party basis have strong
public health messaging
people will have legitimate questions
about the vaccine strong public health
messaging will
should allay those fears and should we
should allow people to get the questions
their queries answered
secondly mobilize our nhs and our public
health
infrastructure and resource them
properly to get the vaccine out quickly
but thirdly deal with some of the
dangerous
nonsense uh nonsensical anti-vaxx stuff
that we've seen
spreading on social media which erodes
trust in the vaccine
we're we're calling on the government
we're asking the government that we will
work with you on a cross-party basis
to put in place measures to deal with
that anti-vax nonsense that sadly
is still available on social media
platforms now of course we're talking
about a very serious issue here but i
just need to reference the fact that
thank you very much for battling the
rain
it looks like pretty torrential
conditions uh where you are and
you were told the interview started
[Laughter]
we were you were talking there about um
dangerous content online
anti-vaccine content and you you as you
say you've written to the culture
secretary asking for
legislation on that and what exactly are
you intending
to do here you know what kind of
penalties how how would that work
well i just want to reassure your
viewers this isn't about
stamping out the ability of people to
ask questions about a vaccine
lots of people are going to have
perfectly legitimate queries and
questions about how the vaccine would
affect them how it affects their
families
how it affects you if you've got a
chronic condition or if you've got a
condition where you have a
your immunity system is suppressed
asking questions about the vaccine
is entirely legitimate which is why i i
just want to really really push this
point
we want to work with the government on a
cross-party basis
to build public trust in that vaccine
but sadly if you go on social media
today
you can find poison
garbage that is spread conspiracy
theories suggesting that the vaccine is
being developed by
big global business people who want to
use it to insert
microchips into people it is all
nonsense and
the fact the anti-vaccine campaigns
which we've had for
forever really they've had they've been
around since vaccines first came on the
scene
in the 1830s erode trust
and they play on distrust on public
institutions
so that's why it's important we work on
a cross-party basis
but it's also important that the social
media platforms
take some responsibility now they have
taken some action
on the voluntary basis but they still
got a lot further to go
so we're saying to the government we've
talked about an online harm spill
we've talked about holding social media
platforms responsible
we will work with you on a cross-party
basis to get that legislation on the
statute book
because the last thing we want to see is
the is vaccine
vaccination levels drop because if this
stuff spreads
unchecked online so are we talking about
financial criminal penalties here and
who would be the subject
of that is it the person who posts the
false information
or is it the company the website that
hosts it
i mean i think it would be the platforms
because i think that i think that
their business models are based on the
sharing of incendiary comments
so they they will have mechanisms to
deal with this and i have begun to deal
with it but to be frank i i mean i came
on
i you know i looked on this uh you know
on my phone just this morning and you
can still find stuff
on uh you know on tick tock and and so
on so
look we want to work with the government
to find a way of stamping this out i
think it would involve financial
penalties the government
the government have said we'll have an
online harms bill we've been urging the
government to bring that bill forward
but i think this is really important now
we know it's been going on for a while i
actually came on
um on your show about 18 months ago to
talk about
online harm in the context of teenagers
harming themselves and sadly in some
instances even taking their own lives
so we've known this has been a problem
for a while but given that
vaccine uptake is going to be so
important in the next few months
i think there is an urgent even more of
an urgency now
in getting this fixed yeah i certainly
remember the interview about the online
harms um you're talking about the
importance of the uptake
for a vaccine should people be forced to
take a vaccine
no i don't think so we did
and it was actually about 150 years ago
i think introduced a compulsory
vaccinations
legislation in this country and it led
to mass demonstrations actually oh
excuse me oh no
oh i'm the uh
this is um if you need to take
this is going to be one of those ones
this will be one of those clips that
will go viral no doubt
um the point i was making is we did
actually in the united kingdom introduce
compulsory vaccination legislation in
the 1850s as it happened and that was a
long time ago
but it just led to mass demonstrations
it led to the anti-vaccination league
and our
vaccination rates actually fell so we've
always
since then always adopted a voluntary
approach in this country and i think we
should continue the voluntary approach
but that's why it's so important that
the political parties work together
that we mobilize civic society to
promote the uptake of a vaccine
and that we all have a responsibility to
allay people's fears to deal with
people's concerns and
answer people's legitimate questions
from a vaccine but don't allow trust to
be eroded
in the vaccine as well that's a very
well handled
umbrella there i'll try not to keep you
too much longer but who do you think
should be
prioritized to get the vaccine first
i think i think the um the the the
committee of clinicians who make these
decisions have suggested that we
vaccinate the the elderly and the
vulnerable in care homes and health care
workers
i think that's the right priority list i
would hope that that
committee also looks at the impact on
those from ethnic minority communities
because we know that this virus has had
a disproportionate impact
on those from ethnic minority
communities but i understand
why they've made an age-based set of
recommendations
because at the moment we know that this
vaccine appears to protect against
infection but we don't know
what it does to transmission yet we
don't i mean that is a
that is still a great unknown which is
why to come to a question that you put
to george usus
i suspect we'll probably have to carry
on
following the social distancing rules
for some time into next year
and i think the sooner the government
give us clarity on that the better
because
until we know how this vaccine impacts
on transmission
some of these rules that we've had in
place are probably going to have to
continue
for a good part of next year as well on
brexit
um we spoke to some kofi on the program
who said that if the government tries to
reintroduce parts of the internal
markets bill then there will not be
a deal it won't be ratified by the eu
george eustis came on the program
straight afterwards and says the
government
is going to try and reinstate uh parts
of the internal market spill
it also became pretty clear during the
interviews that the two sides are still
a long way apart on fishing
and that the deal could fall apart on
fishing
it doesn't look like the deal's going to
happen does it
well we obviously hope this will be a
deal i mean this is a time i mean
because of
the virus the the economy of this
country has taken a massive hit people
are
desperately worried about their jobs and
livelihoods and we know that getting a
good deal with the european union would
be better for people's jobs would be
better for businesses
in this country and i'm sorry to say
boris johnson told us he had another and
ready deal i mean he's got a
he got a thumping great majority in his
in the general election a year ago
on the basis that he would deliver a
brexit deal so
really they he's got to deliver on on
his promise to the british people and
get that deal
okay i'm going to let you go inside and
warm up i hope you've got a towel and a
cup of tea
waiting for you and thank you very much
dr nash with her thank you